hello everybody uh welcome
i'm grandmaster mircha parli grass
and today we're going to talk about the
isolated porn in the ending
so i chose a few interesting examples
um let's talk a little bit uh
about the isolated pawn obviously um
it is good to have an isolated pawn in
the
in the opening or in the middle game and
as you as you know the side of the
isolated pawn can try to
to mount an attack or has
for example strong squares in the center
because of the isolated pawn
so it's a lot about space advantage and
dynamics
however in the ending once the the quiz
are off
for example um
it is a
hello hello there it is not so good to
have an isolated pawn but
it's not the end of the world either so
the side of the isolated pawn probably
should
activate the pieces and
[Music]
try not to get another another weakness
like the isolated pawn being one
weakness and
if he gets another weakness then it's
not good
um the examples from today will be
how to play against this isolated pawn
so first of all
we should uh we should uh block it
we should stop uh the advance of the
isolated one
so in this case uh the isolated pawn is
uh
well well defended uh hello hello there
how are you doing um also
it is um it is a good
thing to to simplify
to to exchange some pieces but we have
to be careful which pieces
uh to exchange especially we should
exchange
the opponent's active pieces
and
also for example the open file is
important
and also a typical idea is to try to
create a second weakness
for example here we could try to create
a second weakness
by playing f3 g4 later on
because on with only one weakness it's
difficult to
to win to win such position
such positions and then there is another
thing uh if we blockade
the pawn like we do here for example you
can see we also control the c2 square so
uh it's not possible for a rook on the c
file to
to get into our position
but if we block it then we cannot really
attack the pawn so it's a trade-off so
um if we want to take the pawn then our
knight should probably be
on c3 or or f4 in order to
to attack the uh the isolated pawn
in this position for example the knight
is uh nicely placed
but we need to play um around it like
maybe the point should be to try to get
the file or to
create a second weakness or something
else because we cannot attack
the pawn directly look at this the pawn
is defended although this bishop is
is quite bad but it uh it still defends
the bishop
uh the the pawn
okay so this is uh back to the game
uh this is a game capablanca
versus takeman
from 1913 so classical game
played more than 100 years ago
um anyway black uh black is to move here
with his last move black just exchanged
the queens which
uh was definitely not a good idea so he
exchanged the quiz on
one e2 and here black
like to move just uh takes the
the c file uh
in order to to activate the rook and
bring the
bring the king into play so okay my
question to you is what should why do
how
how do we proceed here
and yeah you can write in the chat
so i explained the position a bit and
now
up to you to find
the good moves if there are any
of a rook trade well as i said
white should uh
why should simplify the position but if
we exchange the rooks then uh
uh yeah if we exchange the roots then we
lose some
some of the dynamics of the position and
then
maybe white is still slightly better but
you see black has the pair of bishops
and we cannot attack so so easily the
d5 pawn so it is better to
it is better to keep the rooks on the
board
uh h3 follows but that's not
particularly active
well yeah h3 is not not really active it
could be considered but then
it would give black time to go g6 for
example
so yeah knight f5 yes knight f5
is uh very good this is what what you
played
i just want to mention that for example
if knight f4 then there is g6 followed
by king g7
or exchanging this bishop is actually
quite bad because then black really has
a pair of bishops
so knight f4 as i said uh the activity
of the pieces
is very important uh in this type of
positions and here we have this
this opportunity to to jump to f5 and
uh we should we should go for it before
black
goes for g6 and uh
take this opportunity
all right um now black played the
king f8 just to defend the bishop
there was a my question
to you is what was the point of this why
not bishop d8
[Music]
um
what did the white uh have it
have in mind here
96 very good yes the point is 96
attacking both um
yeah indeed it activates the king if it
takes on e7
yeah 96 then uh
yes actually we eliminate this
[Music]
bad bishop but
[Music]
there is another point here
uh 1941 well if 94 we just exchanged
a good knight for for a so-called bad
bishop because
it was on the same square
as the isolated pawn we get the file
well there is something else here
at some point we need to we need to take
material so here
it is possible to just take on f6
yes very good bishop f6 and then
rook d5 and now you see bishop b2 is not
possible because
so what happens if bishop b2
checkmate very good very good checkmate
guys
so it's not possible to take the b to
pawn and then if black goes rook c7
for example yes
very good then white can just go rook d2
and you see all these squares are
defended so
black cannot enter with his
rook and then okay it's why white has
white is upon up and little by little
can
can improve the position
[Music]
all right very good so that in the game
black played
i'm fine thank you black played king f8
and now again we need to continue
actively because otherwise we might just
not get much of an advantage
so in the game
white
can you help me
is bishop f6 not possible well bishop f6
then i guess just taking here
yeah and you see now the king is on uh
the king is on f8
so we don't have the same the same idea
as before because now b2 is hanging
the king can escape and actually maybe
black could be even better here
but no there is something else
knight ed4 yeah probably knight
knight d4 also but it would allow bishop
d8 so
in the game white just uh
thank you thank you uh
white just took one e7 so now we have
the opposite colored bishop but our
bishop is more active than
the opposite bishop so as i was saying
uh
activity of the pieces is very important
in these positions
94 it's difficult to win
only because of the isolated pawn in the
ending so it has to be something else
like here
okay black has the file but no
points of entry on the open c file
or look at this very active knight here
and very annoying pin
while the black bishop here it's
not doing much it's it's passive
all right and here um
this knight f5 was uh was again a threat
and it was quite annoying
probably black would mark time with
more pieces live the world yeah okay but
now it's black to move so
black would go something like rook c5 or
rook c4 but then
you see knight f5 check king here
to defend the pawn you could take on f6
and jump back with the knight and then
this
these pawns look very very ugly
so black decided to defend against this
and played g6
but now the pin is uh
now the pin is very very unpleasant
[Music]
and how do we continue here
well apparently we cannot reinforce this
pin
there is no way to to do something here
so the bishop is well placed the knight
is well placed here controls also
c2 square keeps the pawn so so it's not
too advanced
but it's not so active anymore because
f5 pawn is f5 square for example is
defended now
so as i said we cannot win with just uh
one weakness so we need to create
another weakness now it's time to
uh one hour the lecture lasts for one
hour
uh we need to gain space on the
king side so there we go f3
with idea to gain space g4 h4 even king
f2 to bring the king
into the center so this makes perfect
sense
and here it's very difficult for black
to
to make a move for example if he leaves
the
uh he cannot play kinky six to one pin
because
of this knight and if he goes rook h8
for example to play h6 then
we can move to the c5 threatening here
he has to go back
and
[Music]
well no no this this rook c1 is much
stronger so now take
take and after king f2 um
the king intends to go to just go to e5
for example
and again the pin is very unpleasant
probably he will have to go h6
and uh suck a pawn
so if we think about it black's position
is very difficult already
in the game i think he took a practical
decision and he played h6 here
just give up a pawn all right
capablanca took the pawn what else and
now he played the
well he played 97 just in time because
otherwise white goes back bishop g5 and
there will never be this idea with h6
anymore so 97
okay now we have uh now he managed to um
pin
maybe he's trying to bring the knight
over there to c4 and there are opposite
colored
bishops so
h4 it was played knight c5
bishop f4 96
um yeah i think this uh
this is an important moment of uh of the
game
and here white uh
what what do those white here by the way
in this critical critical moment
but probably this critical moment was
[Music]
easily forgotten so
bishop g3 yeah bishop g3 i think it's a
bishop g3 but then he takes on d4 and
probably he wants to go rook c2
something like that
well in the game
in the game pablanca decided to go for
the opposite colors
uh bishops
ending and he took only six
i think this was maybe a good practical
decision because he won the ending very
easily
[Music]
but i would prefer here knight b3
[Music]
take the knight on rook d2 uh yeah this
is what this is what he did
this is exactly what he did he took the
knight and b2
i think knight b3 or b3
well b3 could be the same take here and
try to go rook c2 or something
maybe b3 could make sense because when
you take here you could take with the e
pawn and then
try to play rook rookie one
anyway i just think knight b3 is much
stronger because now bishop e5 is
returned
also in some cases it could be
root e2 for example or even knight e5
sometimes
so we just avoid the opposite card
bishop's
endings and this this would be good
but as i said kappa blanca
just took on uh took on e6
king takes and now rook d2
and uh yeah it's a healthy pawn up also
again we have this isolated pawn but it
doesn't feel so weak
uh now it could be weak but it doesn't
feel so weak
in the game black played the rook h8
maybe maybe it was also interesting to
go b4 with idea to
push a5 and bishop a6 just to activate
the bishop but
of course white would the white would
have advantage
in the game he played
rookie chain well yes we could just
bring the king
on the dark squares but it was not so
easy
because now the h4 pawn is under attack
and uh capablanca played
rook c2 just to
enter with the rook 2 to c7
it is not of course it is not possible
to take on h4 because after rook c7
the game is uh is just lost for black
bishop here there and rook a6 and
with such an active rook black would
simply lose
but black went uh rook c8 here
in order to trade the rooks and now of
course white could go rook t2
and try to play with the roxon
he took on c8 and we we reached this
opposite card bishop's ending
that is very interesting and in the
beginning i thought white
was easily winning but after analyzing
it for some time
i changed my mind and i think white
still has chances to win but
most likely it could it could be a draw
um okay i'll not show you all the
all the analysis here in the game white
played king f2
logical move to bring the king in the
center
and here black made a
mistake
why is the white king not active that
much well
white is white will activate the king
but black has also
ideas to uh to create the blockade here
in the game black played okay i'll just
show you the game
and then i will show you what i think is
my improvement
um in the game white
uh black played d4 in order to activate
his pieces but he gave another pawn and
now there are two pawns
uh you know he has two pawns down in an
opposite card bishop
ending and uh after d4 after taking on
d4
king d5 k3 white
just one descending by pushing uh
g4 next and uh creating the past
h4 pawn so bishop e6
um
well he called it sacrifice but uh he
probably thought it was uh
lost a3 the ending was difficult anyway
um so this is the game and now white
uh okay put the bishop to g7
and black resigns because uh there is no
way to stop g4 h5 and
creating another passport it's uh
is decisive however
i analyze this position and well it's
not
it's not simple at all but i think maybe
black can
can hold by playing something like king
e7
in order to make room for the bishop to
to bring the bishop to to c2
or d3 this reaction it would be a good
square d3 and then
it can attack the white white
pawns from from behind for example
and also it would be useful for black to
go a5 a4 if possible
so i'll just show you some lines but of
course it's
uh it's out of the scope of this
class so for example king e2
bishop f5
b4 bishop b1 just to put more pawns on
the
hello there a3
f6 so you see now the bishop is uh
the bishop is well placed g4 king f7
king d2 bishop a2 and he can put the
bishop to c4 for example and then
uh just attack this white pawns uh
if the white king goes
further like something like this so okay
if he goes back then
it's uh he can always attack the the f3
pawn
take and okay now the a6 pawn is going
to be lost
but black is in time to play this
blockade
and even though he loses the d5
pawn i think this position is a draw
because
um black can defend f5 pawn and so if
they exchange this then
uh here everything is blocked and this
h4 pawn is
controlled and otherwise
if if white
yeah easy to understand otherwise if
white goes
g4 not to allow this bishop f5 idea as
i showed then black can go
f5 with idea of course to exchange one
there were chances for for a draw and i
didn't i didn't find a way to win but
[Music]
[Applause]
maybe i missed something
yes yes the connection is okay
um all right so maybe there are some
problems with the connection i
i hope not my connection seems to be
fine
uh okay let's uh do you see
do you see me well other
oh there was a short connection problem
okay okay i see
well it's not on my side i mean
or i hope not okay but i think now
everything is fine
okay okay good to hear that
okay thank you guys uh let's move on to
the next example
and
[Music]
voitacek versus freshine
played in
2011.
so okay we have again an ending with an
isolated pawn
the d5 pawn and here we can see that
white is uh much more active
the knight is attacking here while
black is defending so let's see how
how this went
uh well the first thing what i should do
here is to gain some space
i mean there is nothing wrong with rook
d1 rook d8 and then
f3 followed by g4 but in the game
white just played the g4 immediately
[Music]
black goes h6 in case of g5
the problem is that white would go 92
and white gets this f5 square
which is very unpleasant for for black
so
black avoided to play g5 for now he goes
h6
knight d to 92 this is d2 square
um
well i don't think it works to to give
up the
isolated pawn here
so black should just uh defend i mean if
he gives the pawn he just loses a pawn
it's not
it's not enough compensation in this
position
so okay f3
rook d8 rook d1 so
now black is defending and white is
attacking but it's not possible to
to take the pawn obviously um
black went g6 also note that white
doesn't have e4 because the d7 rook is
defended so e4 he can just take on e4
okay for now white improved the position
of the king king f2
king g7 and now he played
h4 actually yeah h4 is good
it has to be done and with idea to play
g5
uh disrupt this knight and then take the
d5 pawn
but king g3 yeah kg3 was also to be
considered because the king is
better here than he can go h4 g5 just
like that
so
well in the game he played as i said he
played h4
now black
[Music]
changed the the strategy he played the
g5
and uh he's uh
yeah h4 g5 it's it's good but okay it's
not so easy to
do it immediately even now because he
he can take and then he has knight h7
but in the game black played
g5 with the idea to
disrupt his knight and then he can go
knight g8 knight
97 uh yeah
the thing is if you if you go
okay you can go 92 with idea knight c3
to relocate the knight
but if you go 92 and 94 then you won't
be able to attack the pawn and
he could just put the rooks on the other
flies
and well the pawn is you know not so
good but if you don't attack it you
cannot take it
you know so that's why
he goes h4 and here for example if
rook c8 would idea to get some some
counter play
then black would go
now white would go rook d2 i like this
look
here because
we defend the a3 pawn yes when
g g5 happens we will reroute the knight
to
f5 obviously rook d8 and now
we can go king g3
for example here not g5 because he can
take a knight h7
and g5 false
so that's why we first need to prepare
this
and uh some move a6 i don't know
now g5 works because we have king g4
and we defend this pawn and uh
rook d5 is 195
is coming so with the with big advantage
yeah that's why in the game black
decided to
not wait
any longer and played g5
and after
pawn takes pawn takes knight well the
idea is
of course to bring the knight to to f5
it's
it looks very good he played knight g8
so he wants to bring the knight to e7
where it defends the d5 pawn and also
controls the f5 square so it's an
interesting idea
um 94 97 actually
black cannot cannot allow this knight to
f5 so
white when king g3 now black goes
rook h8 well rook h8 it has an idea
and the idea is to as i said once the
knight is on d4
we don't really attack the d5 pawn so
the idea is to go rook d6 rook h6 with
counter play down the h-file
so what do we do now what do you think
so far so good we maneuvered the pieces
all looks fine but uh
we kind of stuck so how to proceed
rook d2 which rook and
yeah we could do this but as i said at
some point we need to
we need to do something the knight is
nice here and
looks really too all right knight to b5
one knight to b5
it could be in order to bring the knight
to c3 but
i'm not not really impressed by it
well e4 maybe then there is
room d6 with rook h6 b4 again it doesn't
stop rook d6 and page 6
yeah e4 of course not take because of
knight e6 check not knight f5 because of
knight fighter
but black can go rook d6 and rook h6
rook c1
maybe maybe also rook c1 i don't know
it could be possible but at some point
um
yeah ruxin also is not threatening so
much
uh can we exchange the knights
well we could but it's not uh
is not really what uh what we want to do
so if we exchange the knights
and then go for this pawn but um
we would get the rook ending and
[Music]
is not so it's not so clear for example
black can go rookie 7
here and pressure on
on e3 or he could root d6 or page six i
don't know again
probably rookie seven
uh so the time has come to push
on the king side
y to end f4 and we need to create a
second
weakness on the
well plenty of ideas but at some point
we need to
we need to make some progress so it's
time to push
f4 and we can see that this knight on e7
is not controlling the e4 square so the
knight cannot jump to e4 if the knight
was on f6 i
probably wouldn't advise this f4 move
but like this we need
to push here because we have more pawns
here
and we can gain some some space and also
create a second weakness we need to
create a second weakness look at this
he is well defending the the weakness on
d5 so
we need to create some some other
weakness
and here uh black went
king g6 which was not the best but it's
difficult to to defend such positions
it was actually better to to exchange a
pawn
when you have a more difficult position
it is advisable to exchange pawns
exchange pieces but also pawns so here
it was good to exchange these pawns and
then
after a move like a6 for example
white would go rook c1 well with
advantage
but um still
there is some work to to win this game
for example
c8 rookie one and then with idea rookie
three
f5 black's position is unpleasant
and on the long run white can
increase his advantage anyway as i said
it's not easy for black to defend and
black went king g6
and here white missed a good opportunity
can you
can you help me with
can you help me find this good
opportunity for white
what do you think
how should we proceed here
well
king f3 uh f5 yes
f5 f5 is the
[Music]
yes in the game he played knight f3
actually in the game he played knight f3
but f5 is just good because
[Music]
he's with jack and then
then the point is if king f6 then there
is knight f3 with idea
e4 and of course as i said black
had to exchange some pawns also
e4 could be an idea now so
rook d8 now he can prepare it like rook
d2
first i think this is important rook d2
and now the idea is to go
e4 finally and black's position is uh
is very bad
for example king g7 then
uh yeah f5 yeah f5 here and then if king
g7 then there is a
e4 you cannot take the pawn because of
knight e6
and knight c6 uh just knight f3
yeah no good square for the for the
black king
yeah this was a good good opportunity so
f5 followed by knight f3 with uh with a
large advantage
probably winning but in the game he
played knight f3
and now black finally took
yeah like that took f6
so suddenly it was it wasn't so clear uh
i mean still white has an advantage but
after f5
king f7
um
white looks better but black can also
defend
so here probably it was better to go 94
in order to bring this guy to e6
with a better position but who knows if
it's enough to win
in the game he played rookie one
rook c7 as you can see black defended
the pawn and now
is activating the rooks knight d4
a6 rookie 3
knight c6 now he can also challenge the
the white knight
knight f3
rookie seven
um
g5
well here black black went wrong
he probably had to take on a one e3 but
it's not uh
easy to allow this check
this is unpleasant position anyway he
took on g5
uh yeah and here what went wrong king g4
this was wrong
uh what what did he have to do
what did you play here
knight g5 yeah knight g5 is good knight
g5 work
rookie 7 was the way to go
so for example rook e7 knight takes
yeah knight takes knight g5 is with
check
[Music]
and now king f6 that is king g4 very
important with idea rook
rookie six probably this is what he
missed
yeah so he goes king of f8
if king of faith king f4 well white
white is better the win is not
guaranteed though
anyway in the game white played king g4
which
seems logical but is not enough because
now white
black had a chance to to make a draw so
after rookie 8
rook takes root takes
[Music]
rook h1 obviously we need to to keep
some looks
uh here black uh black make the mistake
he played d4
but he had
some ways for example rookie 4
king g5 rookie 3 would have made a draw
because white defense uh
um if white uh defends the
the knight then just on key 4 and if
check then
95
[Music]
still with the draw
but also uh
no not at d4 also 95 and this ending
uh could be a draw but black
should have to be precise here like here
only k8 to
prevent from d7 so this ending is also a
draw
however this was the
the last move before the time control
so the 40 is smooth and black goes
d4 just trying to get some counter play
but now after knight g5 uh
his position is just bad maybe k8 could
still be
a good attempt but he played king f6
king f4
and now you can see
why to back the opponent black position
is very unpleasant
uh probably king g7 was more more
fighting here
he played the d3 he was
taking everything on this pawn and after
94
king f7 uh rook h3 the pawn uh
the pawn is just gone so he lost this
pawn and then uh
the game was uh was pretty much over
he cannot defend like this because of
uh check there so he goes d2 and after
rook d3 he
he just resigned
okay very interesting game and
destructive
and um let's move on to the next example
uh it's a game pano mario versus vallejo
ponz
played in 2003
rapid game of course we have the
we have the isolated pawn yes pushing
the pawn too far
but he missed some tactical
opportunities there
so white has a nice position and
as i said it's all about activity in
this kind of positions and here we can
see that white's king is
in the center so the king is more active
white
black king is uh farther away from the
center
while it is black to move and black
played rook c8
rook fc8 which is a good move because
it clears the the way for the king
towards the center
rook c8 roxy one
okay now is the fight for the for the c
file i think
black's knight is better placed on c5
because it can
jump to e6 for example and challenge
white's knight from d4 so
black goes 96
he has to do it and because if
what happens if king f8 for example
to just bring the to just bring the king
into the center
what strong move
can white play here
roxy 2 very good very good so that's why
knight e6 is important because now
now it can go look c2 and double the
rooks and
black would lose the fight for the c
file
which the c file is very important so
after losing the file uh
the file for the c file as you can see
in such a line
uh black's position is uh is unpleasant
here
but black played well black played the
knight e6 challenging the knight and now
rook c2 is not
is not an optional anymore white played
knight f5 here
to keep the knights on the board
king f8 rook d1 logical just to
bring the last piece into play
and here black played g6 okay g6 was
uh was an okay move
he had another option as well but
let's say g6 it's good knight e6
and now what should black do here
how to proceed
this knight is looking pretty active
here
on the other hand next move it can be
attacked by the king
so
rook d8 you're saying
roxy6 where rgd8 would just
uh
give b7 that activate the king but how
okay rook d8 would would give the file
so
it's not uh
is not so good
not only the file maybe black and white
can already take on d5
yeah white can just take on d5 so it
gives up the d5 pawn
uh roxy6 roxy 6 was the the good move
here
you take the yes he also took on c1
change rox and k7 yeah this is this is
what he did he
he changed the rules but uh this is what
i mean by exchanging the roxy gives up
the c
file and then white has an advantage
because it's the activity of the pieces
also so
you will see white will not necessarily
win because of this deep one but
he will win because of the activity of
the pieces roxy six was very strong here
indeed and
it was an essential move because now
black doesn't give the the b the c
file and
[Music]
for example if
knight b7 he can take on c1 with rook b1
and take on b2
so no problems and
if rook c6 then just
taking here and then the knight could
could be trapped
so again black black was fine after
rook c6
rook d8 well rooney to rook d5 king is
seven i think there is rook
d1 and white can move the knight the
next move
so yeah black 2. c1
rook takes and now
now yeah now this is an instructive
already black is doing bad but
k7 is an extractive move so how to
proceed with white here
what is your move
this is uh
is the knight trapped
this is a nice tactical trick knight b5
you want to
you think the knight is too forward
there and
you want to bring them to bring the
knight
home rook c8 very good
very good and very nice so knight b7
there is rook b8 and then b
to false it's not possible but rook c8
is very strong
and then he has to take knight c8 and
actually the a7 pawn falls and
uh the whole position falls apart
so yeah that was the trick
the same if room d8 here the same thing
rook c8 could happen and again with the
with a bad position for black because uh
idea could be even knight
knight b6 but uh
knight b6 knight c7 king d4 and black
cannot defend the d5
that's why black saw all this and he
played the d4
in order to get rid of this isolated
pawn i mean no more
no more troubles with the isolated form
we still
cannot really take on b7
um i think here
a good move would have been rook c8 but
it's a
long line and i don't know it had to be
calculated till the end
it seems that white has an advantage in
this ending but i'll not
i'm not going to details so
in the game white played more practical
he played the
b4 idea is that now he wants to
finally take that pawn on b7 since
rook b8 does not
attack the white pawn anymore
and here okay maybe this was the last
opportunity for black
black played rook b8 to defend that pawn
but that was that was slow instead
it was better to try something like a5
just to activate there b5 now
exchange and something like a4
with idea to fix this pawn there and
it is for example after move liking
d3 well there is no rook d8 because of
luxi
white is better but still there is some
fight
anyway room v8 looked like the normal
move
but now white did us before and
after rook c8
check
rook takes knight takes the king ending
is
almost winning for white and we can see
once again is not just the isolated pawn
is the activity of the pieces look at
this the white king is better placed
here and the knight is uh
is active and already attacking uh
the black bones on the queen side
so a6 in order to save that pawn
now took on d4
the king
starts pushing 96
uh you want to play e4 well e4 is
not might not be such a good idea maybe
he has a
knight knight f4 check
i need to go here and i don't know maybe
he can activate the knight afterwards
so
what even go even go d3 here and you see
now after king is three he can take on
on g2
yeah no no no this is uh yeah this red
this tree here
now here he took on d4 and now he's
activating the king
very important king e4
uh with a large advantage for for white
and i will show you the game until the
end
so uh the thing is
white has a very active king and the
knight is well placed and
he can also push the the pawn so in the
game he played h5
king e5 look at this king you
don't even know where it's heading to
h4 96
uh this was black's problem all along
this
this king so p5 king f6
going for the f7
pawn now black went knight f4 f98
there is h3 and as you can see black is
kind of lacking moves for example king
g8
then g3 and
g4 with the winning position so he went
knight f4
knight f7 knight g2 95 but now he loses
a pawn and
also the king is still very bad
um he was pinning his hopes on the h
pawn but it
doesn't really work
f4 and now he's not uh he's not in time
he's going to take
he can take the h pawn but this one this
pawn will uh
is going to queen
king f6 knight f3 king g7 now there is
no more
check anymore and this pawn just pushes
and black resigned here
so i hope this uh three examples were
were instructive and that you learned
something about the isolated pawn in the
ending especially how to play with the
stronger side
i repeat first of all it's good to
to block the pawn so that it cannot
advance
then exchange in some pieces it's uh
exchanging the active pieces is a is a
good method
and let's not forget about uh
creating a second weakness and gaining
space
on the king side in our case and
i want to repeat uh the activity of the
pieces
is very important as we saw in all the
examples
uh let's not forget about the activity
of the pieces so
it made it made a difference in in all
this
in all these games
okay this is all for now thank you
thank you so much for watching and uh
see you next time bye bye